my my whole thing is right now look it
looks like joe biden is going to win
that's that's just it thank you trump
just did a press conference where he
said there's voter fraud and all the
stuff
um i think trump should take every legal
avenue he can
and i think the reason is we've got talk
now of uh what is called
truth and reconciliation commissions and
there's a bunch of articles popping up
where like people are rejecting it
saying like okay fine bring out the
guillotine this is ridiculous we're not
doing this
and um some articles are saying let
history judge trump trump and we're just
going to like you know
move on uh trump still might win we we
we don't know
we we might get a call soon but it's not
looking good for donald trump
and there's a lot of people who are
concerned about how the vote was
tabulated and
uh we're going to get into all this
because i we do have an article about
how the media reacted to trump's claims
and his pr
press conference about fraud but i think
the big the big first story is about
steve bannon so before we get started
make sure you smash that like button man
it really really does help
mash it just just give a little tap and
uh subscribe hit the notification about
we do the show monday to friday live at
8 pm
and uh we're hanging out with uh see mrs
coughlin sheamus of freedom tunes
must you insult me every time yes i want
to warn you guys
my face is really itchy today i don't
know what it is it's really dry so if
you see me scratching a lot that's it
it's not it's not the nose though i've
got i got three water bottles
this time we want to talk about the
voting totals a very important total was
reached
i know how many water bottles i need per
episode of tim cass because i went to
the fridge twice last time he's a
drinker that's right
there you go it's confirmed well also as
you know i mentioned drew's here uh-huh
look at you there you go so you you were
just on the ground and all the although
yeah i was in dc
uh i think the mpd pretty much has it on
lock i mean
if anywhere is going to be on lock i
feel like it would be dc what if
everything just
calms down it's like the least likely
i'm saying nobody nobody wins nobody
loses like the republicans keep the
senate they gain in the house but lose
the presidency and then everyone shrugs
at each other and goes home
whatever i mean antifa definitely
doesn't want joe biden they've made it
very clear so they're rioting in denver
they're riding in portland
even in la they're organizing although
all the big heavy blue states
i think that's what a lot of people are
making the mistake is they think that
you know moderately that a vote for joe
biden is going to make like these
radicals go away but it's just not
i think i think it's going to get worse
yeah i think and not just the left i
think we might see action from the right
i really do
if if donald trump uh loses
and we got these videos and like i'm
seeing a bunch of stuff where people are
saying there's statistical anomalies
that make no sense
someone put out a graph showing that the
wisconsin voter turnout is five standard
deviations above
the the the average which is which which
they argue is a statistical
impossibility
i don't know if that's true i'm bringing
up to say there are people who are
outright saying
here's data that suggests i'm right and
there are people who are going to buy
into it
which brings us to the first and opening
story steve bannon
condemned banned from twitter after
suggesting
violence as a warning to federal
bureaucrats the first thing i want to
say is i did not watch
the steve bannon show the war room he
got banned from i guess twitter and
youtube
and according to forbes they're saying
that steve bannon
was calling for beheading top-ranking
intelligence officials
as a warning to federal bureaucrats now
i got to i got to be careful because i
look i didn't you know show me the quote
and uh i'll believe it but it may have
been a figurative thing i don't know
entirely all i will say is if it's
really true that steve bannon said
something like that that's that's that's
nuts man we don't want we don't want any
of that
they give us the key facts say bannon
suggested firing fauci and rey
before saying he'd actually like to see
their heads on pikes outside the white
house
okay so that's what is is is that
figurative or is he literal what do you
think i think he's probably being
figurative but i don't want to get
banned from youtube so i'm going to say
it's literal and we should all condemn
no i mean i i think that you could say
yeah you could say that like that kind
of inflammatory rhetoric is not helpful
right now and condemn it totally agree
but i would also say that it's pretty
clear that steve bannon doesn't want to
actually go out and be head people
i would i would bet money on steve
bannon does not want to behead anybody
safe bet yeah at least himself at least
himself yeah maybe he's calling for
others no i don't know i don't know it's
like when greta told people to
stand up against the wall oh that's
right that's right that's right nobody
banned her
exactly greta never got banned so for
those that aren't familiar with that
context greta tunberg said that she
wanted to put politicians up against the
wall and everyone went
and then it turns out like in swedish it
just means to like hold someone
accountable if you can kill him but it
probably is the same route
yeah you know what i mean like what else
does it mean i mean you could you could
literally like hold up a prosthetic
bloody head of the president on twitter
and not yet banned but
retweeting oh that's twice like you
could do that once kathy griffin
griffin does it like once a month yeah
that's crazy
that's a really good really good point
right now kathy griffin just posted that
photo again
yeah nothing nothing
well i honestly i think that makes life
unsafe for journalists
if anything they're the real victims
here that's true
they always i always are this rhetoric
is very hurtful to them
my friends the truth and reconciliation
commissions are going to happen
i don't know i don't know exactly what
that's supposed to be but we've had npr
call for it robert wright high profile
leftist and all and like tens of
thousands of people were like yes that's
right
and i think i think it starts with i
honestly i think it's a it's a bit
like you know talking big you know you
know you know how the left likes to add
words to their words to make their words
sound smarter than they really are
exactly like my lived experience instead
of my experience which literally means
the same thing same exact thing they say
truth and reconciliation commission and
what they really mean is permanently ban
you
from every platform on the internet and
make you go live in the woods in a mud
hut yeah
yeah well i don't know about you you're
the worst i mean i'm downstairs
sounds pretty good you ever watch that
ancient technologies youtube channel
no is it the guy like he just builds
huts out of mud in like the woods it
makes like
stuff no no he makes legit tech like
he builds like like rain traps for like
catching water with leaves and
he he like literally built a house and
created like a stove
and he could like make clay pots that's
cool yeah but how are you gonna watch
his videos you know how to do that in
the woods once they ban your youtube
channel
we'll make a a hand crank generator to
charge my phone
but they won't let you on youtube
anytime you try to log in they'll boot
you back off i will watch
downloaded videos of it who's going to
give them to you tim i'm going to get my
neck out for you i don't want to get
banned i got
i got them downloaded already oh off off
off the internet so uh so that's you
know
real quick to go to that point you know
i i think the hypocrisy is pretty
ridiculous right because big tech will
always say
we'll ban people we'll de-platform you
because you say something that could put
someone's life in danger in the real
world
right but kathy griffin can hold up a
severed head of the president that's
fake
right well that's okay because you got
to understand that that was just power
and she was a woman so you know she
doesn't have power over trump because
trump's a man but steve bannon is a man
and you know he's talking about using
his his male privilege so
and also she was jking for sure 100
yeah she was just joshing so it's okay
it's 100 fine guys that's comedy we're
not supposed to take everything everyone
says literally all the time i said
bannon also suggested the violence
against fauci and rey could be part of a
civil war so i'd like to see the full
context of it yeah
i'm skeptical now yeah i would like to
know what you did yeah i would like to
know it too questions and doubts
well trump was barely going to fire
fauci and ray if he got if he got
reelected
it doesn't look like he's going to be
re-elected we don't know for sure
this is also tiring mm-hmm but i'm i'm
looking forward to the uh the truth and
reconciliation so i can learn what the
real truth is and how orange man is bad
i just want to be reconciled and i want
to know the truth what's so bad about
that that's all i want
it's it's the waiting i can't stand
reconcile with us
when it is one side calling for truth
and reconciliation you know it's going
to be good when like they're all on the
same team
you know it's actually going to be the
truth i think
we are uh you know when i'm watching
these videos and i see
these violent right-wing extremists
showing up to maricopa county
and they're running around smashing
windows oh i'm sorry
that's antifa in portland and denver
sorry when i see these trump supporters
kneeling in prayer in front of the
maricopa
county you know board of elections um
i'm not worried at all
when i see the violent riding even
though they're winning
then i kind of get worried well there
was a there was a reporter
yes that's what i was going to say
tweeted and she called them extremists
she did so now
if you are a trump supporter and biden's
america you are now the extremist
not antifa not black lives matter
radicals trump supporters yeah so
good thing we've always supported biden
here dude i think
i think the united states is dangerously
close
to uh some kind of mass factional unrest
i don't know what you want to call it
but i'll tell you this the media
will not be satiated like they're
they're they're they're vampires
for the orange man right yep they've
been they've been suckling the teat of
trump
for news for the past four years and if
trump is out
they're gonna be like you ever see the
movie uh daybreakers um
oh yeah so is you've not seen it oh come
on you guys
it's it's this movie it's like ethan
hawk and he's a vampire but everyone's a
vampire
and they have humans in farms but
they're eating too many humans right
and so what happens is when they're
blood deprived they start to mutate into
grotesque monsters
the media is going to do that they are
going to be
this hasn't they already no but you
drill it's going to be like gollum in
the ring
the orange man okay there's a scene a
nice ring to it
there's a scene in the movie listen
where a vampire walks up to like a
coffee stand and he goes
they say twenty percent blood only and
thresh's coffee and he goes put more
blood in my coffee
and she's like i can't and then goes
right he goes nuts and starts attacking
her
the media is going to without trump they
are going to be desperately looking for
anything and anyone to fill that void
yeah
and they're going to be sitting there
like all the journalists are going to be
in a room staring at each other
like shaking and sweating and then one
guy's going to go huh
hug you and they go trump supporter and
they're all gonna start writing about
like anything you do they will they will
go off and that's why i think um
like when they're calling trump
supporters extremists once
uh if if trump loses if uh he might we
don't know
um if he does then they've said it trump
supporters are far-right extremists
and anybody who says any like anybody
who probably supported him is going to
be called a foreign extremist
and they're going to say these
extremists were defeated and it's going
to be
which is probably why the gop is silent
right now yes to them yes that's really
because they're fully aware of that
right they're afraid
they're scared they won't stand by them
they're always afraid they're such
chickens yeah exactly that's why trump
was great that's why people voted for
him and so much of the base
liked him because he was actually
willing to stand up to the people about
complete contempt for us
so check the republican establishment
well check this out keith olbermann
he tweeted at 7 15 it is necessary to
remove and arrest
the president of the united states
tonight i have a question about this yes
maybe maybe you guys can help me with
this 100 isn't his side winning
yeah what is wrong with him that he
thinks we need to arrest
sitting president of the united states
tonight also isn't that a weird thing to
say before the elections actually been
called yeah you need to go in there
isn't it a weird thing to say when
they're winning and they have the power
and now they're calling for the arrest
of the president
and they're calling his supporters
extremists and they're calling for truth
and reconciliation commissions
this is gonna be fun they want they want
to have a truth in reconciliation with
those extremists
yeah it's going to be awesome yeah yeah
exactly
it's going to be peaceful bernie's
bernie bernie knew he had to do it he
bowed to the establishment he gave it
gave him whatever they wanted is it
chicken i i love how bernie went from
like the millionaires and the
billionaires to
i'm a millionaire and i'm friends with
the guy supported by the billionaires
yeah
exactly vote for the guy supported by
wall street and multinational
corporations
excellent work bernie sanders joe biden
is my friend it's true i like him he's a
good man
remember when elizabeth warren just
completely lied about him and
he was like still calling her his friend
and then he went when he walked up to
her at the end of the debate she likes
are you lied about me bernie she thinks
he lied she was trying to just get press
attention
what slimy people she's like i believe
you called me a lot i tell you i tell
you what the problem is right now man
you're not doing this right now
you wanna know you wanna you wanna know
what the the the easiest evidence that
democrats
are just basically the low information
voters is that they try and get the
youth vote
and they're trying to get 16 year olds
to vote exactly quite literally people
who have no idea what's going on
no it's totally insane the democrat i
mean we were talking about this
yesterday but if your entire strategy is
to get celebrities on television to tell
people who would not otherwise vote to
vote maybe you are just trying to
harvest low information voters and
taking
advantage of the fact that we have a
very ignorant population in this country
and also with respect to lowering the
voting age i mean think about
the voting age it was 21 originally in
the united states it was lowered to 18
later on
and by the time you were 21 you'd been
living on your own and supporting
yourself for several years people were
usually on their own by the time they
were 16.
so you had real world experience before
you could ever vote nowadays the voting
age is 18
and you're just finishing high school
you didn't want to college yet and they
want to lower it to so honestly if you
want to college you might vote worse
because a lot of these kids come out
dumber than they went in
but it's like they want to lower the
voting age just 16 on top of that
completely insane
but there's a reason it's because they
know people who don't know anything vote
for them
it's kind of sad yeah thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you